サッブ パパッス アカラナン クサラッス ウパサンパダ サチット パリヨ ダパナン エータン ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
今日の法話の説法の布施
法施がございまして あのと
大泉孝さん 自分のご両親の幸福を
幸せを願って 今日の会場の日をね
布施として寄付せていただいていてます
ご両親のもうちょっと高齢で
そんな状態もそれほど良くないとはメモを書いてありますけどね
まあそれはまあ我々どなたのも運命ですからね
いつかこの世を去らなくてはいけない
しかし 私たちはお世話になっている方々に恩返しをしなければいけないんですね
この中で この世の中で人間が一番恩を受けているのは両親なんですね
それにはかなわないんですね
いくら人から助けてもらっても
両親の優しさ 優しさに心配する気持ちにかなわないんですね
献身的で 何でも子供のためにやってあげるということでね
ですから 自分の両親のために
この今日行った布施の行為はね
本物の親孝行ということになります
特に布施の中で この前回も説明しましたけど
あの法政っていうのはね
仏教 ブッダの真理を語ることに協力するということは
布施の中で一番トップグレードになります
なぜならば 物質的に助かったことではなくて
この説法を聞く皆様も
それによって心清らかになって
皆様の死後の来世までも
あるいは解脱に達するためにも役に立つことですから
これほど人を助けることはできません
これ以上はね そういうことで
今日の功徳で 法性の功徳で
この大泉孝さんのご両親にも
まあ本当は今回はお母さんと
次回はお父さんと 本人が分けてますけどもね
まあそういう分けようじゃなくて
両親 お父様とお母様にも幸福が訪れますようにと
心の安穏 安らぎがありますように
で 死後 すごい幸福なところで生まれて
智慧が現れて 早くも輪廻転輪廻の苦しみから脱出できますようにと
お布施なさった方はそういう祈願をしてください
できることなら ご両親に理解できるならばね
まあ両親がわかる言葉でね
あの両親のね お父さん
お母さんの幸福を願って
そういう法事を行いましたと
法事なんかわからないんだったら
どんな言葉でもいいんですよ
なんか私は偉くないんだけど
なんか偉いお坊さんからね
両親のお父さんとお母さんの幸福をね
願い祈願していただけましたから
お母さんもお父さんも喜んでくださいと
そういうことで 皆様もご一緒に
このご両親 この大泉さんのね
ご両親に幸福が訪れますように
安穏がありますように
輪廻転生から早くも脱出できますようにと
3回サードゥをして回向してください
はい サードゥサードゥサードゥ
はい では 今回のテーマに入ります
あの 今回は私はほとんど使わない単語なんですけど
心のトリセツっていうのは
で はい 心について喋っていきます
あの できるだけわかりやすくはするんだけど
あの 本当言いたいところいっぱいあって
それは書いてないんです
だから一番基本的に誰にでもわかりやすいことを書いてるんですね
変なタイトルですね 皆さん認めますかね
味噌汁の主体は味噌っていうこと
これ出さなかったら 味噌汁の一番大事な役目
誰がやってるかって言っちゃうと
味噌はというでしょうね
おそらく間違いです ほんのちょっとの味噌でそんな主役できるわけないんです
水がなければ何も成り立ちませんだから
だから主役は味噌です
それでも味噌と具がなければ味噌汁ではありませんね
主役はあるんだけど 脇役も必要です
だから味噌汁っていうのは
この ハーモニーですね
いろいろな役柄の 誰も出しゃばってはいけませんね
味噌だけ出しゃばっちゃうと不味くなっちゃうしね
具ばっかりあって 味噌の味噌の量がすごく減っちゃうとね
またまずいしね あるいは具も味噌もうまく合ってますけど
出汁がないとまた不味くない
だからそのすごい見事な
このハーモニーということは必要なんですね
はい 皆さんにわかるところ
その行だけ どうしましょうか
俗に言う心は 心はカタカナにしたんですね
一般の方々が言う心は
受想行識の組み合わせです
一般的に心あれやこれやと言うでしょう
別に仏教を知っている人だけじゃないでしょ
世界中人間が心を心と何のことなく使ってはいるんですね
だからいて心を知っているのかというと
それはなかなか勉強していない
心の勉強は心理学がありますね
心理学でも心の勉強をしていないんです
だからこの束で４つの束なんですね ４
つのもので編み込んでいて
これは切り離せません
だから この４つにもそれぞれの別々役柄があるんです
味噌汁と同じなんですね
水の役割 味噌の役割 具の役割
出汁の役割って見事な四つですね
それで互い似ていないんです
似ていないんです それで味噌汁に大根ちょこっと入れたりして
大根と味噌は同じもの
全然違います 豆腐入れる
豆腐っていうのはもともと親が大豆でしたけどね
味噌の親も大豆でしたかもしれませんけど
今は別なものなんです
元になった大豆の 1片もないんです
味も何もです ですから
それぞれのものに別な役割があるんです
だからそれははっきり分けて仏教で心の説明するんです
心の主体は識という と名付け名付けている
知るという働きです で
書いてるんですかね はい
この知るということは
皆さんあまり気づかないんです
はっきりあるんです これはあの味噌汁の...食べる人々
ああ この具がいいねとかね
今日は出汁がすごくうまくいってるんだとかね
ちょうどいい味でだなとか言うんだけど
あれ 本当に大事な役割をやっているのは水なんですよ
水がなければ出汁はどうしようもないんです
ただ 今 あの あの 人工的に作ったあの出汁もあるでしょ？あの粉とかね
あんなものを舐めてみてください
飽きたくなっちゃうんです
おいしくないんです 皆様
味噌に慣れてるんだから
味噌をそのままちょっと舐めても大丈夫かもしれませんけど
私なんか舐めたらえっ？と思っちゃうんですね
こんな味は何やと だから別々は大したことないんですね
それは水 水が割り込んできて
うまく調和してくれて
あの美味しい味を演出するんですね
だから心の場合は この知るということはすごい大事な働きをしているんだけど
あんまり気づかない 心の場合は受想行の働きを重視します
だから私たちもこの味噌と同じく
心といった皆様も知っているのは
この受想行の何かでしょうね
まあ大体みんなあの行の方でしょうね
今日はちょっと元気ですねとかね
今日はすごいやる気がありますよとかね
あれ 心なんですね 肉体にやる気がないんです
その場合は心っていったってこの行なんですね
だからいいアイデアが浮かんだとかね
私の心にいいアイデアが浮かんだとかね
私はいつでもアイデアいっぱいだという場合は
想という 2番目をチェックしているんですね
知る機能に気づきません
はい そちらのちょっとあまり説明する必要はないんで
知ることは根本なんです
目が開いたら あ セロテープだと
これ目が知らないと 目がそのホールを知って
それからデータが中に入って
名前も全部取り出しちゃって
感情やらいろいろ取り出して
この知識というものを作るんですね
認識 知識を知ったとかね
例えば人にあんたこのそれを知ってますか？と言ったら
知ってますよと いう場合は
この知るだけのことじゃなくて
組み立てたことな知るっていうことは
言っても根本的に知る知る知るだけなんですね
あれ 知識ではないんです
だから心が臆病でゴキブリのように隠れていると思うんですかね
それの聞いたのは あの
いまだに心を研究するために科学のメスが入ってないんです
だから実際 我々に心あることは誰だって知っている
魂がないということは
もう科学者はしっかりと証明している
魂がないことも 神がいないことも
それは問題ないんです
科学的に立証されているんです
ありえないんだと だって
進化して生命が現れたってことはもう知ってるんだから
しかし心はあるかというと
なかなかデータ取れなくなっている
データ取れないんです
でも私たちは怒ったり
恋したり 楽しくなったり
落ち込んだり 物事を考えたり
いろいろやってるでしょうに
そこで科学者たちがこの脳の変化をチェックして
そこを計算して それが心だと
もう今までそこを勘違いしてるんですね
脳にほんのちょっとの化学変化が起こる
それだけじゃなくて 必ず電気が流れるんですね
その電気は普通の電気と同じなんです
だから脳のニューロンの間でニューロンって何でしたっけ？神経細胞の間で電気が流れている
それは心だったら 電気も心でしょうに
東電がすごい心持ってますね
それだったら というわけで
あの心は科学者には見つからないんだから隠れているですかね
だって体中調べて見つからないんです
それで若者は恋する場合はね
体全身でそれ感じていますね
だと思う 恋したことないんだからね
いろいろ本読んで言ってるだけで
あまり はい 私はいたって簡単に
心の証明します 科学者じゃないんだからすごい楽チンですよ
何でしたっけ？機嫌が悪くなった炭素
炭素でしょ 見たことがある
えらい調子が悪くなった炭素
炭素っていうのは まああるではなんとか炭とかね
なんで炭素使ったのかというと
体は炭素ベースでできているんだ
物質です 他の物質も入ってますけど
ベースは炭素なんですね
カーボンなんですね あの
まあちょっと間違うんだから
私はたまたま英語の単語を使います
これ カーボンベースですね
あの遺伝子もモレキュールももう細胞もね
だから水はパーセント ７
パーセントありますけど
まあしかし この何か硬いものが必要でしょうに
硬いものを作っているのは炭素です
ベースにして 骨だったらカルシウムというのはたくさん入ってますけどね
だから自分が機嫌が悪くなったということは
おそらく 炭素がカーボンがね
機嫌が悪くなっちゃう
ね そうすると危ないんですね
皆様もたまたまね バーベキューやる時でも買ってくるでしょ
炭を もしバーベキューやろうかなと買ってきた炭が機嫌が悪くなっちゃうと
あるいは怠けちゃうと
どうにもならなくなっちゃうんですね
物質に考える 感じる能力があるはずはないんです
じゃあ体の 98%ぐらい水だったら
私が怒ったらもしかするとあの水が怒ったでしょうね
あるいは私は人に恋をしたならば
あるいは水が恋していることになるでしょ
それだったら川なんかに行ったもんじゃないよ
大変なことに 炭素が痛くなって叫ぶことがない
有機物質にタンパク質
ホルモンなどは明日どうなるのでしょうかと悩むことはあり得ないんです
だから大体体っていうのは炭素だけじゃなくて有機物体でしょ
それからタンパク質ものがあるんですね
この DNA がずっと RNA 作り出して作り出して体を管理しているんですね
RNA というのはタンパク質なんですね
ではないんだけど 純粋タンパク質でもないんだけど
RNA を信号を出すと
タンパク質必要なものを作ってくれる
だからまあ 1万  2万 かなりの種類のタンパク質はあるんですね
体を自分作るんです 作れないものは食べて入れたりはする
それはほんのわずかなんです
まあホルモンも本当はタンパク質なんですね
タンパク質には何か 明日どうしようかなと悩むことがある？ないでしょう
我々は悩むんですね 明日どうしようかとかね
そうすると 私のどんなホルモンそう悩んでいるんでしたとかね
私のどんなタンパク質
どんな有機物質が それはあり得ない
物質は物質です 有機であろうか
そうでなかろうが関係ないんです
純物質に決してできるはずのないことばかり
この体の中に起きているんです
大量なこと起きているんです
今喋ってるでしょう 水が喋るわけないでしょ
まあ音ぐらいは楽器でも出せますけど
じゃあ楽器に喋らせることできますかね
決まった音を出すだけ
と それでも心は隠れていると言えるのでしょうか？と
だから私はよくみんなに言うのはね
体を隠してもね あんた心は隠せませんよと
人間には自分の心を隠すことは
人間だけじゃなくて どんな生命体にも自分の心を隠すことは全く不可能なんです
だからよくはっきりと
太陽のように出ているのは心なんです
それでも科学世界では
現代科学世界では心はよくわかりませんと
何か数字で測ることができないとできないんですね
科学世界では でも今私はここ立っている
手足を動かしている 喋っている
考えている いろんなアイデアをいろいろ整理整頓している
すごいことをやっているでしょ
それは心がやっているんです
はい それから分析に入りましょう
分析はいくつかあります
あの分析 1 で 2つに分けてみるんです
2つの 1 ちょっと後回しにして 2 出しちゃったんです
これパーリ語でルーパというんですね
ルーパとは仏教用語は色なんですけど
物質でできている体なんです
純物質組織だと理解しましょう
だからこのこの生物学者やら医者いうことをあまり気にしないでください
身体は物体です 他の物質と全く同じなんです
有機であろうか そうでないただのケミカルであろうが関係ないんです
だから地球上にいる我々はね
命を構成するためには必ずしも遺伝子でできているアミノ酸でできている物体が必要だと思っているんですね
そう決まってないんです
他の元素をベースにした仕組みも現れるはずなんです
それはもう今 私たち人間に証拠がないんだから置いておきましょう
身体は仏教は純粋物質として見ているんです
その場合は このアミノ酸も組み立てた合成したものだから
単純にね ハイドリジェン
水素 オキシジェン 酸素
ナトリウム そんなもんでできているんですね
で カーボン フォスファラスは日本語でわかりません
で それからカルシウム
カルシウムのレンジも全部入ってますね
カルシウム ポタシウム
ナトリウム全部入ってるしね
ジンクという何とか金属ですね
入っている 鉄等がありますね
だから鉄あるんだから体錆びるんですよ
本当に だからこの細胞や遺伝子やあれやこれや話置いといて
あれは組み立てたものだから
ねぶた祭りでそこあんな変なでっかい何か山車があるでしょ？あんな感じでどうったことないんですよ
材料で見たらほんのちょっとだから
ねぶた祭りのあの山車ものでも
それは仏教用語でルーパあるいは色というんですね
1番目はナーマなんですね
2番目は色 仏教用語でナームルーパというんだから
2 1 と番号を入れ替えたんです
スーパーナームの場合は
この名という漢字を書くんだけど
物体にできないすべての機能
行為がナーム この場合はもうまとめて心と理解した方がいいんです
だから物体にできないこと
わかりやすいでしょ 例えば人が死ぬ
人が死んじゃったら物体だけ残る
持っていけない こっちは借りたもんだから物質
じゃあ皆様も心を発見したければ
死体と生きている人を比較しましょう
それで死体にできないことをすべてこちらで心がやっているんです
例えば死体は腐る ね 朽ちていく
壊れている 生きている体は？微妙に一応腐っているんだけど
それはまあきれいにするんですね
体にモーターとか何も機械を入れていないんだけど
体が働いているんです
ということは 車でも動かすためにどれぐらいテクノロジーが必要かと
どれぐらい技術が必要かというと
みんなもう専門的専門の人々が組み立てて作っているので
組み立てるのは誰でもできますけど
簡単じゃないんです 車の仕事
ちょっと移動するだけなのに
この移動するだけ人間に必要な役割で
でもそれやってもらうために大変なことをしなくちゃいけない
まずスピードをコントロールしなくちゃいけない
動くスピード それから向きをコントロールしなくちゃいけない
で 他の車とぶつかっちゃうと迷惑だから
そうならないように いろんなもの
バックミラーやらいろんなものをつけなくちゃいけない
あれやこれやとかね エンジンの調子が悪くなっちゃうとそれでパーだからね
エンジンの調子をチェックするメーター
あれやこれやとか入れなくちゃいけない
どれほど大変かと それは何一つないんだけど
私たちには人の体にぶつからないで
壁にぶつからないで走ったりすることできるでしょ？見てください
我々はこの物体を運転する場合は免許もいらない
見事にやってるんです
歩いて人にぶつけてOKが事故を起こしたとかないでしょ？じゃあ自分も皆様体にステアリングホイールをつけている
前から人いる ちょっとここら辺に
その人はこちらが じゃあこちらにとか
ないでしょ だから仏教で心を発見する方法はそういうことなんです
死体を見て生きている人を見る
自分の体を見てもいいんです
死体は呼吸しない 心臓は動かない
それから壊れていく 栄養を取らない
喋れない 動けない 反応しない
見えない 聞こえない でしょ
あの働き群が心ですよ
だからこれを明確に説明しちゃうと
もうかなり日が暮れちゃうんだから
あの まあしょうがないんだけど
例えば私の心臓が心が動かしていますよと言っても
ええと思っちゃうかもね
心は意識できる 意識できないという 2つの働きを持っています
意識できるということは
この思考になる だから思考するということは
心のほんのわずかな仕事なんです
大したことないんです
はい これナーマと言うんですね
要するに物体が生きるものだと認定するために必要なすべての機能
特色が心というカテゴリーです
だから心というのは 1個のものじゃないんです
いろんな機能をまとめて車で言ったら 1個の部品でしたね
部品を正しくまとめたら車と言うんです
そういうことで この物質の中に起こる機能すべて
細胞分裂もね 心がやっているんです
生物学者には この外で実験室でも細胞分裂させることはできますけど
そこはすごいワンパターンになるんです
例えば 人間の細胞を 1個出して
カルショイというんですけど
あれ なんとか液体入れて温度をコントロールして育てる
増えるだけで そこから人間が現れてこないんです
細胞を培養することで
それは単純にコピー コピー
コピーだけで 日本でも一番優秀でやっているのは皮膚ですね
皮膚を培養するんですね
やけどしちゃうと治療として
だから皮膚をほんのちょっと取って
それを培養して で また同じ人の体に移植する
だから体に移植しない限りは
ただ細胞が増えるだけ
培養した皮膚の細胞も我々の皮膚の細胞とは違うんです
すごく弱くて あんまり役に立たない
そこで移植したらさっさと成長して
医者の指令も何もなくちゃんと皮膚になるんです
日本の場合は技術はすごく進んでいるんだから
やけどした跡も消えちゃうんです
ということは 細胞は物質
体につけたら心とつながるんです
それでちゃんとハーモニーでオーケストラやるんです
40兆の細胞たちは それぞれ自分の仕事をみんなと連絡し合って
ハーモナイズして この生きるというオーケストラをやるんです
心は一個の機能ではなく
グループファンクションなんです
これは日本訳すればどうなるんでしょう
グループファンクション
機能の集合ですか 機能の
集合 集合かな  車に例えてくだいて面倒くさい
車にはたくさんの部品があるでしょ
部品は自分にはまるっきり別な仕事があるんですね
どんな部品にも車は元
先へ先へ進んでやろうという気持ちないんです
タイヤにすらないんです
タイヤにできることは一か所で回転することです
あるいはタイヤが勝手に一か所ではなくて
勝手にいろんなところで回転したら車にならないでしょ
だから車のアクセルというのにタイヤがつけて
かなり頑丈なネジで留めているので出てこない
だから一か所で回転するだけ
タイヤは タイヤには移動したという気持ちにタイヤにすらないんです
エンジンにありますか？その気持ちがないでしょ
だから差し切りもないしね
見てください 誰？どんな部品にも動いてやるぞと気持ちないのに組み立てたら車が動くんです
そういうことで 我々は
この一般の方々は心 心というのは
そのグループのファンクションを見て心と言うんです
仏教はそういうふうには見ないんです
仏教は機能 1個  1個  1個取り上げてみるんです
それはもうちょっとかなり難しいんだからやめます
はい 分析に入ります 分析はいくつかあります
また  1 ループ  2番目の命の分析
ループというのは体ですね
だから仏教的に地水火風にした方が皆様にも覚えやすい
あの元素リストを覚える必要はないんです
タンパク質の分子構成を理解する必要はない
これ面倒くさいんですよ
かなりややこしい 一つのホルモンの分子構成でもかなりややこしい
だからそんなことは置いておいて
地水火風にした方が 4つしかないんですから
仏教では だからこの物体は地水火風です
2番目 ヴェーダナというものがあるんです
ヴェーダナっていうのは自由と書くんだけど
感覚 感覚はわかりやすい
体が苦 楽 不苦 楽を感じるんです
私の体がそう感じるんだから
動くことはできているんです
今もどんなボタンを押せばいいかとか
私は感じないと 見てボタンを押しても
手で触ってボタンを押しても感じてやっているんです
感じなきゃ終わり もう何もできない
2番目 サンニャーと言うんです
3番目 サンニャーと言うんです
サンニャーは概念ですね
青い 丸い花などなど あの
あの 何て言いますか ラベル貼らないと困るんです
後でまた思い出すためにレーベリングするんです
瞬間に我々は 必ず言葉必要じゃないんです
赤ちゃんもそれなりの周りなる物事の分別できます
だから赤ちゃんのお店もちゃんとラベルを貼って
これはこれ これはこれという風にあるんです
だから私たちは 例えば最初に生まれて
最初にバラの花を見て
もうラベル貼ったんですね
それでお母さんがバラの花だよと言ってくる
そうすると この言葉も覚えてつなげておくんです
それで繰り返しちゃうと
見た瞬間にあ バラだと決まって終わっているんです
それ かなり仕事起きてますよ
でもこれバラでしょ これ花でしょと
いとも軽々く言うんだけど
このラベルシステムがなければ
それはできないんです
それが常に起きてるんです
常に起きてるんです  4番目
サンカーラ 業 で パーリ語でこれを複数形にしていて
で サンニャー 1個にしているんですね
私の説明では サンニャーがたくさんある羽目になりますけどね
お釈迦様の中策から見ると
1個というふうに決めることは難しいんです
この青い丸いとか書いたのは
このお釈迦様の説明からなんです
サンカーラっていうのは衝動で見たい
聞きたいなどなどの欲とその他の感情
アビダンマが発展すると
そこら辺はまあまあそれほど明確に区別していないんですね
もし私に権力やれば 私はこの解釈を変えるんです
サンニャーが膨大なことにして
私だったらサンカーラは小さくするんです
その方が理解しやすいと思います
欲ですね だから常に私たちには聞きたいとか
その欲はあまりないね
で 欲が起こるんです だからその衝動がなければ呼吸すらできないんです
皆さん 呼吸はオートだよと思ってるでしょ？だから呼吸を止めてみてください
どれほど強烈な意欲が
衝動が働くのかと その瞬間に皆様にもう一つ発見できます
例えば 呼吸を止めて 1分
2分いると 強烈な痛みが生まれるんです
痛みはヴェーダナーです
2番目なんです 苦の感覚が生まれる
苦の感覚が生まれると
苦をなくしたいというすごい欲が生まれるんです
それはサンカーラなんです
これ一緒に生まれるんです
だから皆様生きていきたいでしょ？これはサンカーラなんです
反対に死にたくないでしょ
それもサンカーラなんです
両方エネルギーなんです
言葉で 2つだけで 本当は機能は 1個なんです
生きていきたいだけなんです
死にたくないというのは口先だけでわかってないんです
それは わかってない 誰も
5番目の分析は  5番目に
これ５つに分析したんですね
ヴィンヤーナ 識 それは知ることです
六根に触れる対象データを認識するんです
耳に音が触れたら感じちゃう
感じたら あ データデータが入ったと知るんです
これ何だとわからないんです
それから心の中でそれが調理して
何かのアイデアにしておくんです
２から５までの働きは心です
だから私の体を見ると
4 5分の1は物質  5分の4は心の総合体です
心はものすごいエネルギーなんです
物質は全く単純で大したことがないです
はい 分析さん もう一つの分析に入ります
これは皆様もうすごく聞いて
聞いて聞いて何回も聞いているんだから
まあ問題ないとは思います
3番目の分析は六根に分けてみるんですね
六つに分けてみる 六根というのはベースですね
ベースに分けて 3つのベースが見つかるんですね
１ チャック目 そこでこのチャックって言ったら目でしょう
このこの丸い目のこの玉じゃないんです
目っていうのは この丸い玉が光に反応するんです
光よりも色に反応する
あの能力に着くというんです
目は物質です 目玉は物質です
だからいくら進んだ科学はあと百年後で
あまりにも科学は進んで目を組み立てることをできたとしましょう
細胞をしっかり この目っていうのは結構複雑な機械ですよ
かなり複雑なんです 目すらはい
複雑なそれぞれ部品を合わせて合わせて
もういろいろ培養しながらしっかりした目を作ったとしますと
しかし光に反応しないんです
それは体に植えて 体の心とつなげないと
心がそれを受け入れない限りは見えません
だからこの移植っていうのは物質だけで
心臓を移植したら受け入れるか拒否するかという
そこで物質的に戦って拒否しないように置いておく
まあそれだけでも 本当は心が受け入れなくちゃいけないんです
2番目 そうて耳 音に反応する力
3番目ガーナ あの 何でしたっけ？鼻
情報香りとして反応する働き
上情報と書くのを忘れちゃったんだけど
全て情報なんですね 色も情報で
色という情報 音という情報
香りという情報 だから情報を香りにするならば
鼻の仕事なんです えーと
ジューは舌ですね 情報を味として反応する働き
だからここで情報はどうであっても
舌は味だけ認識するんです
だから生きている私たちは
本当はありのままの情報を取っていないんです
こちらデータのグループある
何かデータのグループあるとしましょう
下にこれ理解しないと言ったら
舌理解するのは味だけ
目にこれ理解しないと言ったら
色で計算して形を認識する
じゃあ体で理解しないったら
まあ硬いか柔らかいかふわふわしてるか程度でわからないんで
他は それからかや それは体ですね
心だけ書くんで この場合は情報を束として
反応する働き いわゆる感じることだと理解しましょう
体で感じる 本当は全部感じることなんですけど
体で感じるのは暖かいか冷たいかとかね
硬いか柔らかいかという程度なんです
例えば私にはこれをそちら見て
このそこら辺触ることはできます
触って頭の中でイメージを作ることはできます
私は目で一回見たことがあるんだから
あの過去のイメージを参考にして
ここら辺はこのギザギザギザギザであるし
これはグニャグニャ曲がれるところやと
見る必要もないんですね
触るだけで十分です しかし
舐めて できません 舐めると味しか認識しないんです
だから人に目を隠しをして
何か物体 マイクロフォンでもいいし
なんとかなんとか これ舐めて何ものかと言ってくださいと言ったらできません
しかし 言うんですよ 例えばボールペンをあげて
これ舐めて舐めて言ってくださいと言ったら
舐める 舐めたボールペンでしょと言うんです
その場合 舌の働きじゃなくて体の働きなんです
ベロも体の一部だから
はい そこで我々は命を 5つに分けました
じゃなくて 命の機能を 6個んと分けたんです
この 6個んと分けたのは
心が仕事をする事務所なんです
心は 6つの事務所 窓口を開いて
それぞれ担当を入れているんです
それぞれその担当が 自分がその窓口でデータを受けるんです
目の前で音を立てても
担当違うんだから目は反応しない
耳のところに何か絵をこうやって見せても
耳は反応しない 担当違いますからね
だから絵は目の前に来たら
私の仕事だということで
そこはデータを心に送る
空気の振動があったら
ある波長の振動だったら
耳が私の担当ということで
それを音というふうに心に入れるんですね
それから 6番目 マナ それは識
それは知るというふうなことでも同じことなんですね
物質以外の情報に反応する働き
そこが目の窓口は 物質は 5個で十分です
それで何をやるのかというと
マナは情報を認識したり
合成したり 考えたり 感情を作ったりする働き
目に見えるのはバラの花じゃないんです
見えた情報をバラだと決定するのはマナなんです
そこでそこで終わらないで
あー綺麗でしょうと感情を作ったり
作らなかったり いろいろ
それで私たちは花を生けるでしょ
あれがマナがやっているんです
目から入った情報で感情が引き起こすために綺麗という
よくバランスを整えた綺麗なものやと思いたいんですね
マナが だからマナが自分のイメージを作って作って
手にデータを送って 目からデータを送って
適切な花を持って適切なところに入れておく
それは体をやらなくちゃいけないんです
目は分けてくれる で 分けることもマナやっていて
体を動かすこともマナがやっているんですね
で これは脳みそじゃないんで
とにかく我々の体では脳がすごい仕事をしているんですけど
本当に心は脳じゃないんです
だからマナという窓口があるから
私たちに過去のことをいつでも思い出してますよ
だからバラの花と言うために
過去のデータがなければ
例えば言葉を喋ってるでしょ？過去のデータがなければ喋れません
だから私は喋る単語一個一個
皆様方は意味わかりますね
それは一番最初に教えた時のあの層を参考にしないと
そう思う どれぐらい仕事ですかね
例えばこれはノートパソコン
ノート 今 日本省略してノート
ノートと言った途端 皆様方は心が最初にラップトップという
普通英語ではね ノートということを使いませんだけど
それは日本語でね で 最初にこういうノートパソコンを見て
いいノート これ持ち歩くて
そこでデータ入れちゃうんですね
だから移動可能なパソコンとかね
色々言葉あったのにね
英語のラップトップは直訳しちゃうとあまり日本的には美しくないんだから
ノートにしたんですね
いわゆるノートパソコン
どこでもメモを取ることはできる機械っていう意味でね
それでパソコンの意味は表現してないんです
メモできる機械 いくらでもありますよ
メモできる電子機械はすべてノートじゃないんですね
だからそこで最初にその単語を覚えた意味を理解したことにずっと参考するんです
なんか信じが信じがたいね
それは心の速さなんです
心は物じゃないんだから
あちらこちら行くために時間かからないんです
心が物だったら時間かかるんです
はい その分析 さんの仏教用語を出します
あの六根というのはパーリ語でチャインディというんですね
で 六の対象はチャラマナというんですね
1番目チャック 対象はループ色に相当
対象はサッブ サンガーの鼻
対象は眼で それは窓口の感覚ですね
鼻という窓口には感覚は香りだけ
他何も認識することはできません
問題は 鼻は鼻でありながら体の一部でもあります
だから鼻を触ったらわかるし
鼻に何か刺しちゃうと痛いしね
その時香りは感じていなくて
鼻ではなく体だけ反応しているんです
それから次は舌ですね
管轄性はラサ味 体全体的で
管轄はポッターブ触れること
6番目 マナ マナの職業は大変です
だからダンマーという言葉を使う
ダンマーっていうのは何でもOKということなんです
現象という風に訳す 訳す
心には何でもOK 心には心という窓口に制限ないんです
私たちの心はひどい制限やってますけど
それは我々のせいで 心の制限
心にもともと制限ないよ
どんなデータも処理できる
色と音だけに限ったそれはないんです
五根には現在データしか
窓口にデータ触れなきゃ反応しない
心にはデータあってもなくても大丈夫です
過去を思い出したりする場合は
このマナという 6番目の基本が仕事をしているんです
だからそちらに制限ないんだから
仏教でこれ実験してね
瞑想を実験して 知る能力をハチャメチャ拡大している
だから究極にお釈迦様が拡大したんだから
お釈迦様は知っている
世界はもうどんな人間にもまるっきり敵わないぐらいのことは知っているんだよ
我々 ほんのちょっとの過去しか思い出せないでしょうに
お釈迦様のは次元 無限に過去を思い出してみることもできます
だから心にはそうやって制限も入ってない
心はマナには 色にはね
有機物体が色 音などの物質的な波長に反応を起こす
あれ 眼耳鼻舌身意という
これ体の部分なんですね
それは色声香味触という関係で働いています
そこで意はマナ マナですね
法というデータに反応する
この場合 法っていうのはデータにはリミットがないということなんです
だから 例えばみんな怪獣をイメージすることはできるでしょ？目ではできませんよ
マナでやっているんです
時々人間がお化けがいたんだとかね
幽霊が出たとか ものすごく泣き叫んだりもするでしょ
あれ 幻覚はマナに作ることはできます
実際ある必要はないんです
誰かに幽霊が見えたからって
幽霊がいるわけじゃないんです
実際しないものもマナに認識することはできます
で まあそこら辺 ちょっと世界ちょっと違いますけど
人間が神一度も見たこともないんですよ
会ったこともないですよ
歴史上 みんな神を信仰してきたんですね
神が雨 1個すらくれたことがないんです
しかし 何でも神 神がやってくれるんだと
時期 雨が降ったら農業をやった時はね
現代科学技術使ってますからね
神様ありがとうございます
証拠ひとかけらもない
神が雨が降ったという
しかし 当時の人々は本気でそう思っていたんです
で 本気で嘘を思うことできるんだから
すべて先秦先農の神が作ったんだぞとかね
面白いことがありまして
アメリカでいまだに 42%の人々は進化論を否定するんです
ドカーンと神があっというと言って
いきなり男と女を作ったと思っているんです
いわゆる 10万年前ですです
完璧嘘でしょ そこでデータを取って
ギャロップとしていて
その中で知識レベルをチェックしたら
修士 博士 学者 科学者すら進化論を見ていませんよと
面白いんですね 世界支配している国の連中の脳みそ
心の指導的支配的な働き
心は大体わかるでしょう
物質を指導的で支配的に働くんです
実験室で作れない品物は体で起こるんです
死んだ魚 口から中に入れたら
ちゃんと体に必要なタンパク質を取るんです
そこで見たら自分の細胞になっているんです
では 将来どうかわかりませんだけどね
死んだ魚のアミノ酸全部取って人間の細胞を作るとかね
できるんですかね 遺伝子を入れなくちゃいかんだから
しかし 私たちは魚を食べちゃうと
魚の遺体を食べちゃうと
そちらのアミノ酸を取って遺伝子まで作るんです
だから遺伝子すぐ割れちゃうでしょうに
コピーしなくちゃいけない
コピーするためには物質が必要です
毎瞬毎瞬やっていますよ
心を体がすごいこと それは心が指導してやらせているんです
一番簡単なのは機嫌が悪くなると食欲が減るね
例えばすごい誰か死んじゃったとか
すごいショックを受けちゃうと食欲がなくなるんです
地震が 地震が起きちゃって
自分が避難所に命拾いしましたと
夜も寝られない 疲れているのに
ご飯食べない 体純物質の塊だったら車と同じく
同じ量のご飯食べられるはずなんです
心が管理するんです だから時々我々は食べ過ぎになる
時々ろくに食べてない
時々食べ過ぎにたくさん食べたのに体力がない
時々お菓子を 1個食べてお茶を飲んだだけで元気で働く
はい そういうのは科学的に説明できる
あれは心次第なんです
五根の情報を認識する
概念を合成する 捏造する
妄想する 考える それは意と法のセクションなんです
で 説明 矢印あります 矢印 2番目
意と法の関係 法っていうのは何でもありきですからね
意味は それで何からというと
心が五根の物質情報を受けてって合成するんです
例えばインド人と日本人の前に刺身を出す
日本人の心がごちそうだと捏造する
インド人は生ものを食べませんだからね
あ 気持ち悪い で 食欲までなくなっちゃう
これは科学的に考えれば変でしょ？目は科学
生物学的に機械であって
脳でちゃんと反応 電気的なちゃんと反応を出すとかね
それだったら日本人に刺身がおいしいという感情が生まれたら
世界中の人間に同じ感情が生まれるはずなんです
それは生まれませんね
心は自分好きなように合成するんです
捏造するんです だって私はわざわざと魚の場合
痛い痛いと言ってるでしょ
わざとそれは事実なんです
なんで魚の痛い食べてとか言ったんですかね
これ捏造の問題教える考えもあったんです
確実にこれは死んだ痛いなんて痛いというか
亡骸なんです 気持ち悪いはずなんです
で 美味しいでしょ カツオの遺体がある
ネズミの遺体がある どうですかね
カツオが体大きいんだから
臓器もいっぱいあるんだから
汚さが大きいんです ネズミちっちゃいんだからね
あるいはミミズに死んだミミズがいる
じゃあ皆様に綺麗に刺身の皿を作って
さらに何か何か他のビニール紙でもいいし
銀紙 ホイルでもいいし
ホイルをちょっと入れて
その上に何て言いますか
ミミズを1匹入れておく
写真も食べないでしょ
それだったら 何もなってないんだけど
触れてもないんです ちゃんとホイルの上に丁寧に死んだミミズを置いておく
だから捏造するっていうことはわかるでしょ
それで なんで死んだカツオの遺体は遺体で見えないんですね
それはなぜでしょうかね
なぜ美味しそうやと思うんですかね
捏造です これは心マナがやってるんです
胃がやってるんです 捏造は
それで妄想すること 思考することも胃がやってるんです
目で考えることはできません
だからここまで膨大な量を我々は考えているのに
心は科学的に実証することはできません
あると 生命体の働き 動きや
働き 働き 動き 行為は心が行っている
それが結論です これからちょっとスピードを上げないと
で ちょっとテーマを変えます
動き 働き 行為という 3つ書いたんだけど
英語だったらムーヴメントやアクションなんですね
純物質には働きがあります
物理法則なので その動きを働きではなく
動きがあります この動きを理解することは難しくありません
物質も動くんです でも一定の物理法則で動いているんです
だからすごい理解できます
計算することも予測することもできます
だから天気予報成り立っています
決まってますよ 低気圧だったら
まあそこで雲がかかったって雨になるとかに
そんなのはもう簡単 心が行為します
心は動きません 移動しません
行為します 行為は生命にしかできません
アクションは 生命にしかできません
すごいシンプルなことでしょうに
例えばゴキブリとビー玉を取ってみると
ビー玉は何とかして転がしてあげなくちゃいけない
ゴキブリもちょっと脅しちゃうとゴキブリも走るんだけど
それは行為であって アクションであってムーヴメントではないんです
ムーヴメントは計算できる
ビール ビー玉がどこまで行ってどこで落ちるのかと
だからテーブルの上でゴキブリとビー玉を一緒に落としちゃうと
ビー玉がこちらに行って落ちる
落ちて転がっていく それはわかります
ゴキブリは落ちませんね
走ったらこちら見て下に行って隠れる
もしかするとそれもわかりません
それは行為 ゴキブリの心がやっているんです
ビー玉には心がないんです
例えば 我々は時々こけて落ちることありますね
それは行為ですか？動きです
動きですか？それは舞台から降りると私は転がっちゃったと
それは私が犯す 起き 起こした行為ですか？あるいはただの動きですか
それは動きです 私は行為で落ちてやるそうとは思わないんです
だから体物体だから体にもムーヴメントあります
アクションもあります
しかし ムーヴメントは
物理法則 でステップ踏んだらステップが壊れちゃって
割れちゃったら私の足が中に入っちゃうんです
それはアクション ムーヴメントなんです
私がやったわけじゃないんです
だからこの その 2つを区別してください
すごく役に立ちます 足を上げて歩くこと
座ることなどは心が引き起こす行為です
もうわかった なんで歩くを見せさせているのかと
それは心がやっているからなんです
行為は心がやっている
動き 動きは物質法則です
だから地球は物体だから
地球にはこの動きを全く変えることはできません
自転公転するんで 毎日毎年何百万年も同じこと
心臓の鼓動などは無意識行為などの無意識行為があり
歩く 話すなどの意識行為もあり
2つです 生き物である私は 2つの行為やっています
例えば気づかない 心臓の鼓動やら呼吸やら
血液の流れやら そういうのは意識できないんだから管理できない
だからこれもこの行者たちがくだらんことを研究するんですよ
じゃあ心臓の行為だったら無意識でしょ？なんで意識化できないのかと
それで意識化するんです
成功するんです 意識化したら自分で止めることもできるんです
そういうことで死なないんです
瞑想の結果だからね でも大胆なことはできませんけど
ある程度で 行者たちにその気があれば止めることはできます
仏教はやりません だから何の意味があるのか
何の意味もないんだからね
というわけで 生きるとはすべて行為です
倒れること ホットカーペットに長く座って低温やけどすることなどは動きです
行為ではありません 座ったのは自分だけど
やけどしたのは自分の行為ではありません
それは物質の変化です
生きる働きはすべて行為です
行為は心がやっています
それがポイントなんです
行為はポテンシャルになって
後の行為を変えることが起こるんです
そこでこの行為行為というのは
行為やった やるとポテンシャル的なエネルギー溜まっちゃうんです
そのエネルギーで次の行為を引き起こすんです
川が流れるためには 川自身が
川の水自身がエネルギーなくても大丈夫です
他人のエネルギーで川が海まで流れる
で でも川の水を溜めてポテンシャルにすることはできます
それは人間やるんです
人間やるんだから 川にダムをつけて溜めてもらって
コントロールもする 好きな時水を打って
好きな時止めるとか で
それは人間のセクションは行為です
僕は物質的 物質的な動きですけど
行為をするために判断します
行為をするために判断
私は行為に断ったのは
行為がポテンシャルを作っちゃうんです
一つ生命 が行為したら
その結果 次の行為が現れるんです
だから行為するために判断しなくちゃいけない
例えばこの階段のステップが壊れちゃって
弱くなって 私の足が中に入ったとしたら
それは私の行為ではないんです
それで私は判断しなかったんです
しかし 足が中に入ったら
私はこういうするんです
足を上げてもらうんです
痛いところを触ってもらうんです
怪我でもしたのかと調べるんです
それはすべて行為です
その行為の次の結果が見える
例えば 怪我しちゃったと
それで判断するんです
判断してそのまま放っておくか
手当てするかとかね だからラーメン食べるか
うどん食べるかで判断しなくちゃ
判断によって行為が行為の道が決めるんです
はい 行為は他の行為の行方を決めるから
うかつに行為は危険 うかつな行為
へっちゃらで気楽で何でもいいやということで生きていくませんよ
なぜならば どんな行為も次の行為の決まり手になるんです
これは法則だから仕方がありません
美味しいんだから たくさん食べた
食べると行為でしょ それから次の結果が出てくる
どうにもならない はい
では行為論に入りましょう
行為は 3つです  1体の行為
2 口の行為  3 意ですね
説明すると体で動くことは 1
喋ることは 2 考えることは 3
これパーリ語でカーヤカマ
ワチカマ マノカマと言うんです
心は行為をするために体を道具として使うとき
1と2が起きます 本当は心が喋りたいんですよ
でも心に喋れないんです
体がないんだから ものじゃないんだから
それ心がちょっとした道具を使うんです
マイクロフォンと同じ
例えばみんなに聞こえるように喋らなくちゃいけない
だからマイクロフォンという道具を使うんです
生命体に 人間という生命体に喋りたいという欲が生まれる
欲が生まれても 道具なければ喋れません
だから生まれる時は業によって必要な道具を作っているんです
それも心が作るんです
ものすごい美声の美しい声を持っている人間もいるでしょ
どんな人間も魅力のあるように歌えないでしょ
歌ったら殺される人間もいるし
歌ってあげたら大金もらう人もいるね
私は一番目の部だから歌いません
殺されて欲しくないんだから
ただ 声帯から音を出すだけで
ものすごいお金もらっちゃって
すごい贅沢する人もいる
では なんで声帯の差があるんですかね？じゃあ医学で説明してみたら？できるわけないでしょ
だから声帯作ったのは業なんです
間違った業で心なんです
あの業っていうのはポテンシャルなんです
いわゆる資源 財産ですね
だから心にちょっと財産があって
声帯作れるんです 財産足らなかったら
まあただ喋る程度で声帯を作る
財産全くなかったら声帯は作らない
喋れなくなっちゃうんです
しかし 心が思うほど適切に体は動きません
これ道具だから 例えば私もこのスーパースターのように歌いたいんですよ
本当は でもまるっきり今起き上がることすらできなくなっているんです
なんか喉が弱くなっちゃって
だから気持ちあってもできないんです
そこはすごい面白いポイントなんですよ
我々には世界一美人になりたいとかね
男性はものすごい健康で体力の体欲しいなとか思うだけで
自分の業で作った体で我慢するしかないんです
だから弱い体もあるし
強い体もあるし 体が健康ですけど
目が弱い人がいるし 目がいいんだけど耳が弱い人がいるし
いろいろ しかし 気持ちはそうじゃないんですよ
目が見えない人であっても
できれば見たいんです
耳が聞こえない人でもできれば聞きたいんです
だから心が 思うほど体は動かせません
これはどうしても物体だからリミットがある
軽自動車で F1 車に勝ってやろうと思ったって無理でしょ？ありえない
で 話したけど話せませんということは
例えば皆様も経験あると思いますよ
言いたいことはいっぱいあるんだけど
喋ってみたらろくなこと言ってないんですね
時間もなくなっていて
だから体がついてこないんですね
希望通りに考える 妄想する行為はやりたい放題です
しかし 道具使わないんだから
考えること 妄想することは心だけで勝手にできるんです
やりたい放題 この行為をやるんです
問題は 行為はポテンシャルを作る
そこで言葉でこういうしようと思ったら
思ったほどはできません
で 手を伸ばして人をぶん殴るでしょ
でも思ったほどは殴れませんね
経験なかったら実験してみてください
誰かに対してすごく怒った
ぶん殴りたくなった まあこの我々男たちだから
青年の時期でちっちゃい時よく分かります
それは その気持ちは男としてもう喧嘩を売ったんだから
あいつをぶん殴って粉々にしてったい気持ちがあるんだけど
できませんね  1発殴ったら殴り返して痛くて逃げる
悔しいんですよ なんで？なんであの悔しさは？気持ち的にはもう自分より体格が大きい男を倒したいんです
ざまあみろと 人に触れるんじゃないよと
でも気持ちはあるんだけどね
道具がついてこない だから悔しくはなる
しかし 例えば学校 クラスにいる体が一番弱い子にしたっても
クラスのみんなぶん殴ってはちゃめちゃ怪我させてやってやるぞと妄想することはできます
体で実行することはできません
それで理解してください
体道具使っちゃうとリミットがかかる
道具使わないで心だけで妄想するとリミットがかからないんです
それで行為にはポテンシャルがある
だからどうなる？例えば言葉を喋って人に嫌な気持ちをあげたいんですね
だからどれぐらい嫌な気持ちをあげたいと
もう頭でもうとっくに台本ができているんです
相手が落ち込んじゃって
泣いてごめんなさい ごめんなさいと二度とやりませんと言われるところまで攻撃したいんです
しかし 口が喋ったらろくに喋れないわ
言葉が出てこないわ 逆に相手が笑って終わる可能性もありますね
ポテンシャルは溜まっている
そこで意で限りないポテンシャルが溜まっていて
喋ったところでほんのわずかなポテンシャルが溜まってないんです
ポテンシャルって業に入れ替えると
意で大量に業をやっていて
言葉で少量の業しかやってないんです
意で人を殺したいんだけど
実際はこの野郎殴ってやるぞと言っただけで終わっちゃったと
殺してない 殺したいぐらいの気持ちだったら
もしかすると殴るかも
だから 意のポテンシャルでもうちゃんとすごい怖い悪業している
体で殴っただけ はい こういうの行為の力順
上昇順で言えば 身行為
口行為 意行為なんです
だから意行為はものすごい強いんです
善でも悪でも同じなんです
例 この例で理解してください
宮内庁の公務員が陛下の用事が用事で
あなたに手紙を あなたは手紙をもらう
何か天皇陛下に何かしてあげて
皆様にないんだけどね
よくあることで いろいろね
あれ作ってこれ作ってくださいとかね
いっぱい用事がありますよ
そうすると宮内庁の職員たちは連絡するんです
これこれ持ってきてくださいと
あなたが天皇陛下の直筆で同じ内容の手紙をもらう
もっと具体的に言いましょうか
宮内庁に卵 500個必修になっちゃった
これ 卵をやっている業者なんです
そこで公務員の手紙が電話がでも何か来る
宮内庁のやつはすごい丁寧に 500個送るでしょ
もし天皇陛下直筆で何々人へお世話になっています
この度卵 500 500お願いしますと書いたら比較してください
皆様の心はどのように動くのかと
言わなくてもわかるでしょう
反応の違いわかるでしょ
生きる行為の皇帝は心です
我々は生きているでしょ
心が皇帝のように全部支配しているんです
だから体というあの宮殿の家来に頼んでも
そんな反応がないんです
皇帝直々指令すると ものすごいパワフルなんです
だから 意行為の方が一番上なんです
考える行為は業がすごいんです
道具使ってないんだからね
次は思考の自由 何を考えても自分勝手で自由です
まあそうでしょう しかし思考は貪瞋痴で管理するから
これは真の自由じゃないんです
みんな勘違いしてます
それは自分勝手に何考えてもいいんじゃない？とかね
しかし あなたの思考は管理されています
貪瞋痴で じゃあすごい激怒している人に
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと考えられます
その時は 自由の瞑想できると思う
だから感情が管理するんです
思考は 自分好きなように考えているのではなく
貪瞋痴と他の感情の衝動で思考妄想しているんです
かわいそうね 自分で考えてるんじゃないんですよ
貪瞋痴が考えされているんです
感情が考えされているんです
妄想されているんです
感情煩悩は この 主観です
私の怒りは私の怒り 私は怒ると他の人は怒りません
どの程度怒っているのかと私がわかっていて
他人がわかりません 感情はあくまでも主観的なものです
思考も主観ですから 思考妄想は自由です
他人に変えることはできません
だから精神的に病気になるでしょう
私のことはみんな悪口言ってるんだと妄想する人は勝手に妄想するんです
そんなこと言ってないよ
そんな考えやめてくださいと言ってやめてくれる？やめてくれません
自由に思考するんです
だから自由というのは
私はちょっとニコッと笑ってしまいます
本当に自由じゃない奴隷なんです
悪思考の衝動で地獄に落ちることも自由です
ですから 私は自由で好き勝手なことを考えて何が悪いのかと言うならば
どうぞあなたね 地獄に落ちる自由もありますよと
それだけ 悪思考では良い結果は出てきませんよ
他人の感情をかき回すことで
他の他をマインドコントロールすることもできます
このマインドコントロールというのはそういうことなので
この感情をかき回すんです
感情を貪瞋痴で またたくさんありますからね
傲慢があったりとか 昔
麻原のところとかね 我こそいう最終解脱者の弟子たちやとかね
そういうえらい傲慢の感情を掻き立てて
マインドコントロール治らなくなっちゃうんです
そういうわけで 三業も自由です
まあこれ 日本語フレーズはないんだから
英語のフレーズだから If
you want to call it そう
そう言いたければ あんた方はそう言いたければ
行為は自由ですと言い張ってください
行為を起こすために その子の意志が必要です
意志という また心の一部なんです
欲というふうに理解していたらいいですね
参加行なんですね 自分の心が判断しなくては
行為は現れません 判断しないと足を上げる
運ぶ 下ろすと判断しないと動きません
箸を取る 食べ物を取る
運ぶ 入れるとか 判断しなきゃ行為はない
判断するために意志が必要です
たとえ頭にピストルを付けてやれと言われてやってやっても
やる判断は自分がしたのです
例えば強盗が入って 銀行に入ってピストルを向けて金庫開けなさい
と言ったら 法律では金庫を開けた銀行員は無罪なんですね
法律では しかし 仏教心理学から見れば
ピストルをつけたからといって
自動的に手が開けて 番号を入れ替えて回して回してね
銀行の金庫というのはかなりややこしいでしょう
鍵いくつもあるんだから
自分でやっているんです
裁判では判断能力なかったと
精神状態はおかしかったと
だから無罪だというケースあるでしょ
仏教では業なんです それでも罪を犯しているんです
頭イカれたことが自分の行為の結果
妄想している そこで妄想が人を殺せていたんです
だから喜んで殺しちゃったんです
裁判では無罪になる しかし
まともな人がやった殺人罪よりこの方が悪が重いんです
皆様の頭では屁理屈でしょうと思うんだけど
仏教真理から見ればその通りで
屁理屈ではないんです
まともな人は悩むんです
殺すんですか？殺す どうかな？とかね
悩む しょうがない しょうがない
殺すことで決めるんです
頭は精神状態悪い人はいた
殺した終わり だから業の方が
殺す 殺す 殺す お前殺す
やる やらない やる やらないと悩みがないんだから
衝動は強いんです はい
自分の心が判断するから自由といっても
心の貪瞋痴とそのほかの感情が
判断のYES NOを決めます
だからYES NOを決めるためには
貪瞋痴か感情が割り込むんです
自由不自由ではなく 因縁による結果というべきです
だから皆様方は思考は自由とかね
行為は自由とか言わない方がいいんです
自由じゃないんです 不自由でもないんです
因縁によってそうそういう結果が出てくるんです
ということは 人に悪口言いたいという欲が生まれる
自分に判断できます その場合は
じゃあ今怒りでしょ 怒りは悪だから
じゃあ怒りをやめましょうと
怒らないことにしましょう
自分が心で決めたら怒りが消えます
それは心は皇帝の直々の命令です
だから怒りは消えるんです
怒りが消えたら 相手に悪口を言いたかった行為も消えるんです
行為は業になる 生きる上で自然に起こる行為は業になりません
自然にも行為が起こります
例 見えることは業になりません
見えることは業じゃないんです
見ることは業になります
そこで差が見えるといいます
見える 見る 見えることは業ではないです
見えた 終わった 行為です
生き物だから 見ることは業になります
見えたことで引き起こす思考妄想は業になります
例えば何か見えた それは業ですか？業じゃない
え？次のえ？あれ 何だったっけね？もしかすると田中さんかもね
なんでさっと行ったんですかね
挨拶もしないでとか妄想するでしょ
それはすべて業です だから見えることは業じゃないんだけど
そこから思考しちゃうと業になります
見ることは見ることも業です
業は次の行為の行為を引き起こすためのエネルギーです
心は自分で回転して続くために必要なエネルギーを自家発生します
自分で発生します 心の一番ややこしいところはそれなんで
心も回転するでしょ エネルギーが必要なんです
エネルギーは自分で作るんです
外からもらわない では私はご飯食べることなんですかね
あれは違います ご飯は体のためなんです
体は心が借りたものです
道具です だから道具の修復するためには
物質 外からエネルギーを入れなくちゃいけないんです
心は自分に必要なのは自分で作るんです
エネルギーは業 エネルギーは自家発生するので輪廻転生になるんです
だから肉体は捨てますけど
心はスーッとエネルギー自家発生しているんだからね
次の次の次の次の心を作るんです
時間的に時間になったんですかね
まだ半分以上あります
一応 4時半までです あと 40 分ちょっとあります
みんなクタクタ疲れてると思います
まあ最後までできるかどうか分かりませんだけどね
疲れたまんまで話を続けちゃうと
私のことを恨むんだから
では ちょっと休憩いたします
はい スピーディーに行きます
これ エネルギーの自家発生について喋ってきましたね
物質の場合 比較するとわかりやすい
太陽はエネルギーを自家発生するんですね
太陽の場合は太陽自身で燃えているんですね
宇宙から熱を持ってきているわけじゃないんです
それが徐々に減っていきます
太陽の場合は自家発生ですけど
だから物質は自家発生すると
どんな物質も減って消えるんです
例えば ロウソクに火をつけるのはつけるのは我々です
我々はロウソクにマッチで火をつける
それは人間への行為 それからロウソクが自家発生
自生して燃えるんです
その結果 ロウソクが消えるんです
だから自家発生 物質は自家発生する場合は
その物質が自分自身で燃えて消える
消える 消えることは物質法則です
体の物体から心の知る知る指令で働くと衰えるんです
それで心が歩きなさいよ
喋りなさいよ 座りなさいよと指令しているんです
で 我々は体で歩く 体で喋る
体で仕事をする 体どうなるんですか？衰えていくんです
なぜ体物質だからなんです
皆様方 包丁を買ったりしますよ
包丁を買って 毎日毎日それで料理をして
いろんなものを切ったり
包丁どうなる？包丁の能力がどんどん減っていく
心の寿命は瞬間です 心のもう一つ不思議なことはあります
体は 80年持てますよ
おかしいんだけど まあ細胞死にながら新たに細胞があるんだから
組織として変化しながら
じゃあ有効期限は 80年とか言えます
心の寿命は瞬間です 心は長生きできません
新たな心が次の瞬間で起きます
これはナノスピード ナノ秒のスピードで起きるんです
瞬間 心が瞬間生まれして死んであって
別な心が生まれるんです
ナノの速さで起きるんだから
私たちは気づかないんです
あんまりにも早いんだから
ですから 老いるエントロピー概念は不適切
不適切です 心に心に老いる暇がないんです
生まれて死ぬんです そうすると新しい心が生まれるんです
生まれてばっかして また瞬間で死ぬ
そういうことで何かイメージできません
心はいつだってなんかあるのように気がするでしょ
体に対しては  年も取っちゃった
私の場合は 73 も使っていたんだから
もうボロボロやとかね
心の場合はそう感じないね
いつでも新しい心で頑張っているんです
心が老いないことは大変な問題なんです
心は老いないんだからありがたいではなくて
寿命は瞬間です 他宗教の人々は
魂は永遠なり 死んでも体死んでも魂だけ知らないと錯覚を起こしたのは
このプロセスわからなかったからなんです
心があんまりにも早いんだから
それには一般人には気づくことは不可能です
我々はブッダの教えから理解するだけです
心が業を自家発生するから
無限に生滅の回転 いわゆる輪廻転生ですね
自然法則です だから瞬間の心は業
自家発生する それで心死んじゃうでしょ
死んじゃったら ポテンシャルで新しい心が生まれる
また死んじゃって また新しい心が生まれる
あの生まれた瞬間で行為するんだから
ポテンシャルがあるんです
だから心はいつでもエネルギー切れにはなりません
ポテンシャルだから 過去の行為でもエネルギーとして溜まっているんです
だから心に無限に回転することはできます
解脱とはこの流れをストップすることです
無限に生滅の回転は自然法則です
皆さんの中でも輪廻はおかしいでしょうとかね
輪廻はわかりませんとかおっしゃった方々いたでしょ
輪廻の仕組みはそういう仕組みなんです
だから 明確な科学的な教えなんです
神秘ではない 輪廻信仰する必要はないんです
すでに起きてるんです
心の寿命は瞬間です だから老いる
我々の場合は生老病死なんですね
心の場合は 心は常に病
病気です 煩悩があるんだから
老いることはないんです
エントロピーはないんです
はい 心取り扱いマニュアル
主観を客観に変えるプログラム
はい 今まで言った問題から脱出するプログラム
これからザーッと言います
皆さん瞑想をなさっているんだから
知っていることだから
まあ早くできると思います
暗号を解く鍵は感覚です
輪廻転生して苦しむは無限に回転するでしょう
ここを何か暗号を解いて解脱に達しなくちゃいけないので
暗号を解く鍵は感覚ウェーダナーです
感覚は心を構成する一部です
例えば体で感じる それから考える
耳で音を感じて理解すると
あとは心の働き 耳で感じただけ
誰にでも感覚自覚しやすいんです
どんな人間も犬猫も感覚には自覚があるんです
ウェーダナーには自覚があるんです
犬でも尾っぽで私はよくやりますけど
あなたの尾っぽは余計なことやとかね
言いながら尾っぽを取っちゃうと
怒って尾っぽを体の中に巻くんですね
だから私にからかわれていることには
嫌な感覚もとっくに生まれているんです
だから感じることは動物にすらできます
当然 人間には一番簡単です
眼耳鼻舌身体で苦・楽
不苦・楽を感じますね
目でも苦を感じる 楽感じる
不苦不楽感じる その時です
貪瞋痴が現れるのは 目で見たもので楽を感じたら
もう欲が生まれているわけなんです
見たものはダサい これはなんだこりゃと思ったら
もう苦が感じたんです
苦が我々は瞬間に感情に入れ替えているので
これは気持ち悪いと だから気持ち悪いと決定する前に感覚で取ったらどうですか？と
その時です 自我が現れるのは
感覚 それを発見しましょう
感覚をチェックする 感覚をチェックすると
貪瞋痴が生まれたんだ
自分がいるんだという錯覚が生まれたんだとか
感覚から生まれたんだと
いたって簡単に発見できます
で 体から始まるのは簡単で
経典の決まりでもあります
例えば 耳の感覚感じようかな
目の感覚を感じようかなといったら難しいんです
微妙です しかし 体の感覚はいたって簡単に感じます
触ったらすぐ感じますでしょ？皆様の耳で音が触れることをあまり感じていないでしょう
だからちょっとあれは微妙
だから感じにくい 肉体はそうじゃないんです
だから経典で悟りの道を教える場合は
まず体から観察することを教えているんです
四念処経でもカーヤヌパッサナー１に来るんです
胃に情報が触れる時も感覚が生じますが
初心者には発見することは難しい
初心者でもある程度で目に光触れること
耳に音を触れること ちょっと瞑想していると感じますよ
ただ 瞑想して膨らみ 縮み
膨らみ 縮み入っていると
何か音が触れちゃう 触れちゃうと触れた
なんかぶん殴ったような感じるんです
耳になんかぶん殴っちゃった
殴られたと それは音なんですけど
だからだいたい感じます
でも体で始めてほしい
初めて座る瞑想でもやってみると
あの匂いでもね 触れたということは感じることはできます
感じたとかに 問題は胃なんです
マナなんです 妄想しているでしょ
妄想するときでも感覚が生まれているんです
これはあまりにも微妙で
初心者にはわからない
集中力を上げる必要がある
ですから集中力を上げなくちゃいけない
悩み 憂い 落ち込み 嫌な気持ちなどは胃の苦悩感覚です
それだったらわかるでしょ
悩みがある 嫌な気持ちがある
体別に大丈夫です 体の問題はないんだけど
なんか気分だけ嫌 気分だけ嫌で暗くなってくると
心が苦を感じているんです
喜び 楽しみ 幸せ 幸せ 鍵に入れたのは人間考える幸せです
仏教の幸せではないんです
明るい気分などは心の楽の感覚です
体と同じ 座ってお尻が痛くなったら立っちゃう
立つとあ 楽だっていうあるでしょ
同じことを心でも皆様毎日経験しているんです
興味がない つまらない
面白くない 刺激がないなどの気持ちは
胃に法が触れると起こる不苦不楽の感覚なんです
ですから ちょっと瞑想を進んじゃうと
胃の感覚も感じることはできます
今 やり方を教えました
その都度発見して認識してみます
修行する人は その都度その都度
あのいい人間になってやろうと思ったら自我だから
それではなくて 音が触れた
怒りが現れたと 音が触れた
自我が現れたと その程度でやってみてください
進んでみますね 瞑想 瞑想進んでみたら流れが見えますよ
だから私 今喋っている音でも
瞬間瞬間の空気の動きなんです
だから耳に音を触れて触れて触れて触れて流れるんです
かなり空気の音の速度を知っているでしょ？なんとかなんとかとかね
だからその速度で触れてるんです
光の速度 音の速度というのも無常の速度なんです
それであの人を歌ってるんじゃではなくて
瞑想する人にとっては音は触れて触れて触れて触れて触れて触れて触れて触れて触れて
感じるんです 大体そこまでになってれば
あまり言葉を使いなくなっちゃいますけど
軽々く言葉を使います
音だったら音は触れる
触れる 触れる 触れる 触れる
触れるとかね 音は流れるものだとよくわかります
光は流れるものだっていうのは
あまりにも早いんだからわからない
例えばテーブルを見ると
この色が触れて触れて触れて触れて触れて触れていくんだ
光の速度だからね 観察できません
だから錯覚 あ テーブルはずっとあるんだと
音の場合は音はゆっくりだから流れがあるということは発見できます
であるならば感情も流れるんですね
で 耳に音を触れて触れて流れるでしょ？でっかいひと玉の音が来ないでしょ？ボウリング玉みたいな音が固まってこないでしょ？すごい
もう 40 ハーツとかね
60 ハーツとかね メガハーツでしょ？すごいスピードですけどね
触れる触れることはわかる
それだったら感覚もウェーダーも起きる
起きる起きる 起こる起こる起こる
起こる起こるなんです
これで音から欲が生まれたならば
欲もよく よく よく よく
よくよくと ずっと瞬間の欲の流れが生まれているんです
音が流れてくる そうすると耳に触れて
感覚がずっと流れる そうすると音は音に欲を作ったならば
欲の流れが生まれるんです
一つも一個一個じゃないんです
だから妄想しないで 実況中継で瞑想したら
今私が言うことっていうのは手に取ったようなわかるんです
であるならば 自我 ん？なんか文章間違いやって自我は流れる
自我もですか うん 流れる気持ちでよろしいですか？ とりあえず気持ちでいきます
はい 自我っていうのは錯覚でしょ
たまにするんですね 流れをとって
音をとって 感じたことをとって
気持ちもいい気持ちも生まれたでしょ
その 3つの流れを  3つの川を一つの玉にする
湖にする それは湖になってないんです
川は別々に流れるんです
音という川 感じるという川
音が綺麗な音だったらよくでしょ？欲の川が流れるんです
そこで川 湖 湖やと勘違いしたら自我なんです
俺が今 3本の音を聴いていたんだよと
その俺がいないんです
そういうわけで 皆様に自我意識があります
自我意識が少ない人のでも実感があるんだ
自分という それも実感も川のように流れるんです
心だから 実感は光の速度よりも速く流れるんです
ということは 現象が何一つも止まった固定した実体ではないと発見する
今は私はこの悟るプロセスを言っているんです
瞑想する人には教えてあげません
自我が錯覚であることを発見します
それでくっきりと発見します
流れを湖にいい加減湖やこれはと思わないで
バラバラの流れです 別々似てない流れです
例えば 音の流れと感覚の流れはまるっきり違うものでしょ
それで自我自分という
私は聞いているという実感も
ずっとスピードで流れているんです
だから自我って錯覚あってもいいんです
その錯覚が光の速度より早く変化する流れなんで
実体ではありません 錯覚
錯覚 錯覚 錯覚で流れるんです
その時はだいたいゆるくには悟っています
言葉を使っても 私も説明に言葉を使ったんですけど
これは理屈ではない 体験
発見 悟りです あんなスピードで観察するならばね
言葉使えなくなっちゃうんです
で そのスピードに沿って流れを発見したら
直ちにゆるくには達します
さらに進んでみると そこで一切の現象は無常ですね
流れるんだから生滅する流れです
音であろうか 地球 何でも変わりであろうか
眼耳鼻舌身意で色声香味触法は生じて滅します
だから体に川が 6つあります
眼耳鼻舌身意という光の速度で流れる
そこで外の世界に色声香味触法という
それぞれスピード違うんだけど
早い  6つの川があるんです
早く流れる その 6つの
川  6つの川  12の 川がぶつかるところで自分なんです
内と外がぶつかるところで
自分という一時的な幻想が現れる
その場合 幻想 現象ではないです
ですから 命は瞬間だけです
命の寿命は瞬間 これ指を鳴らす時でも
瞬間 もう何万個も行くんです
ナノ秒だからね 瞬間は
眼耳鼻舌身意とは肉眼ではない
なんか間違ってます これ眼耳鼻舌身と書いたところで
眼目と言ったのは肉眼ではない
耳と言ったのは耳じゃないんですね
あのセンシティビティ
感じる能力のことです
舌と言ったのはベロじゃないんです
ベロにある能力なんです
それは心です 身体にある感じる能力
感受性です これは心の管轄なので
瞬間瞬間生じて滅します
生滅する流れです 耳豚のことじゃないんです
これは物質ですからね
結構頑丈です 感じる聞く感受性
それは心の管轄 ずっと変化するんです
生滅する流れです 無常なので執着することも
愛着 渇愛を抱くことも不可能だと発見します
それでなんだこれ 何に執着する？執着できへんとできへんとわかる
それでその人の心から煩悩が二度と生まれない
生まれないように落ちるんです
心は解放します 解脱します
プログラム終了です それで
はい 今日はこのヴィパッサナー実践の解脱のプログラムでした
プログラムを実行する前にやるべきことがあります
真理を学んで 貪瞋痴の働きを理解します
勉強しなくちゃあかんですね
それから 身口意の行為は不善
悪行為にならないように努力しなくちゃいけない
修行に入る前に 戒律項目はこの目的で設定しています
行為は不善にならないようにとガードしてくれるのは戒律なんですね
自分の生き方の是非がわからない場合は
理性のある人にアドバイスを受ける
まだ修行に入ってもないんだから
これでいいのかよくわからないとかは
誰か理性のある人に聞いて
人の判断に乗った方がいいんですね
自分の意見に固執しないで
それから見解の問題もあります
預流果に悟るためには
見解の障害を乗り越えなくちゃいけない
自分の意見に固執しないで
常に訂正できる構えを取る
我々にはいろんな見解がありますよ
いいんです 別にあっても
しかし データ入る次第
訂正するんだ そうと決めておいてほしい
心は汚す環境と人々を避けることもあります
この人々一緒にいると
もう全く精密な修行はプログラムはできなくなるんです
すぐに理性とは何やと説明します
あのあの宣伝コピーにあったんだから
本当はいらないんですね
貪瞋痴の感情に負けない
感情の奴隷にならない態度は理性です
覚えてください 理性とは何なのか
貪瞋痴に負けないことが理性です
感情の奴隷にならないことは理性です
結構感情にやられるでしょ
その時は理性ありません
客観的に物事を判断することは理性です
行為をするとき 自分の幸福
他人の幸福になるのでしょうかと計算してみる
それも理性です すぐやるんじゃないんです
すぐ考えるんじゃないんです
すぐ喋るんじゃないんです
ちょっと計算する 喋る前に計算する
考える前に計算する どんな計算？自分の幸福になる
他人の幸福になるか そこで幸福にならないと出たら
これは悪行為で その場でやめます
だからその人はいつでも理性でいられます
理性学はまだ続きますかね
理性を持た保たなければ
信仰 迷信などなどはあまり気をつけた方がいいんです
遊びでいいんです それ以上は持って行ってはいけない
そこで妄想と思考 妄想は
妄想は役に立たない 自己破壊になる
結論はない ストップ 執着点がなく
いくつかのループに入って考えが回転する
自分の考えがループに入っているんだったら
それは明らかに妄想なんです
現実離れだったら妄想なんです
思考は役に立つ 論理的です
データを参考にするんです
理性は 思考は データ参考しないと思考できません
結論という執着点があります
思考には結論という執着点があります
時々考えても結論のない場合もあります
結論が 出なかったら さらにデータ情報を探すんです
もっと調べましょうって言うでしょ？これだけではよくわかりませんだからといって
ただ 医者が病気 患者のいろいろデータを取って
うーん これではもうよくわからないと
もっと精密検査しようとするでしょ
医者が思考しています
妄想で診断しません あなた肺炎でしょう
私はもう知ってる それはないんです
データ取るんです データとっても結論がない場合は精密検査させるんです
だから医者の診断プログラムが思考の成り行きなんです
そこから学んでもいいんです
思考は 思考で健康的な楽しみが生じます
思考すると楽しいんです
妄想すると暗いんです
あの あの欲の妄想すると
恋のことを妄想すると
暗くはないんだけど 心は汚れて汚れて悪を起こしてますからね
そのうち暗くなります
で 思考するとなんとなく楽しい
なんとなくすごく楽しいんです
それは欲的な楽しみじゃないんです
健康的な楽しみなんです
これでなぜ岩感覚なのか
副題やったんです これは間違いです
私も気づかなかったんで
気づいたら副題直しますけどね
岩感覚っていうのは変な感覚
それは間違いです 感覚は心の働きを理解するために簡単にアクセス
簡単なアクセスポイントだけです
感覚 感覚っていうのはアクセスポイントですよ
解脱を目指す人は感覚を観察することで実践をスタートする
感覚大事な そういうわけなんです
わかりやすい心理のアクセスポイント
鍵 暗号の解く鍵 感覚は心の働きの一部です
岩知る機能で 最初に感覚を知るんです
一というのは知る機能ですよ
岩何を知るのかというと
感覚を知るんです 最初にそれから妄想するんです
あ 終わりました よかった
あれはちょっとみんなコピーがあったんだから説明してただけです
はい 今 心を清らかにして真理を発見するプログラムを説明しました
一応 心の取り扱い方はそういう取り扱い方なんです
心が命です 心が輪廻転生するものです
ブッダは汚れた心を清らかにして
このものすごい怖い無限に苦しみを回転するんだから
脱出しなさいと言っています
そのプログラムを終わりまで説明しました
以上です どうもありがとうございます
時間的にどうなったっけ？ ちょうどちょっと足りたぐらいだと思います
じゃあ最後の文章で終了します
じゃあ一緒に唱えましょう
ドッカッパッターチェニンドッカ
バヤンパンターチェニンバヤ
スーカパンターチェニッスーカーホントサンデーピパーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しむなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
どうもありがとうございます
カンティパラマンタポーティティンカーニッバーナンパラマンワダンティブッダ
ブッダ